it was the scariest day of my life I
just felt very uncomfortable and I
thought maybe this is part of the
pregnancy they told me that I had
preeclampsia my blood pressure was very
very high over 200 and they had to
deliver her really quick and I kept
telling them that she's not gonna
survive she's only only 23 weeks
at 245 grams there's reservations on
survival they told my husband that he'd
had about an hour with her and she was
gonna pass away but that hour turned
into two hours which turned into a day
which twenty a week
so we do everything we know how to do as
well as we can and after that it's
really up to our babies so some really
have the strength to go through what
they have to go through and grow outside
the womb she's a miracle that's for sure
we had so many nurses but her primary
nurses were just they became friends I
don't want to cry look at all those
signs they made it you know I would come
in and it's like happy birthday mom it's
just I'm so grateful for that I'm just
really proud of them and the baby and to
see see I told you just like see them
transform as parents and see this little
baby go home that usually is like
completely against all odds I am waiting
for this day I want to go we want to go
word if we go home today I don't think
we can forget the state we should
celebrate this day every time huh it's
going to be a special moment for us
I just wanted her to know how strong she
is and how I mean if she can start off
where she was and do as well as she can
be there's nothing she can't do
it was a beautiful experience I love
this hospital everybody everybody from I
mean the staff from the security guard
whenever I come in
how's your day sometimes you just want
to hear somebody asking how's your day I
mean I feel blessed I mean she she is
the smallest baby but